[Music]  my name is jennifer griffin and i've  been at fox news for 25 years well it  was 2005 and i remember that they were  going to evacuate about 21 jewish  settlements from the gaza strip they  didn't want to leave their homes it was  a historic moment and there was a lot of  emotion around this particular event  we were broadcasting live when the  israeli soldiers used a sledgehammer to  break down the door of haim and hannah  gross's house when they opened that door  you could hear  the sobs of the children i think it was  the emotion of being a new mother myself  i had two daughters born it couldn't  help but change you as an individual  they're forcibly evacuating we were  reporting live as they were being  dragged out of their home and it was a  moment that changed me as a reporter  forever  you